what do you do in the bahamas we scuba
dive and we
barbecue
is it just awesome yeah it's great just
being in a nice spot that's really
peaceful and beautiful and
doing something fun like
diving like that's a
that's an adventure it scares me i don't
think i'll ever do it
scarier than it's not it's
jumping in the water in the ocean is
much scarier than jumping underwater in
the ocean
this whole thing of floating on top not
knowing what's inside of what's
underneath
whatever it is you're more comfortable
under the water that's right it's
starving for human flesh you don't know
what's under there but you put on your
goggles you get down there there's a lot
more have you swam with sharks yes with
sharks next to you not a cage yes
how terrifying is that it's
the first couple times it happens you go
oh my god there's a shark and what about
it then you realize they really don't
have a lot of interest in you then you
wish they could get a little closer you
get a better picture
uh they're they're totally have you ever
had an experienced water with anything
you know on the list of like man-eaters
the the tigers the bulls the hammer
heads the great the whites yeah i've
never been in in the water in in that
kind of a situation but yeah sharks yeah
but you've been right up to a shark
right
a shark i've i've been close enough i
could have reached out and touched the
shark yet
what is
how do you feel when you're underwater
with a shark is your heart racing
or are you just completely calm at this
point in the beginning you know you get
kind of conditioned and down and when
they get a little closer there's a lot
of excitement yes but also the whole key
to scuba diving is you know breathe easy
be relaxed expend very little energy you
don't be excited around a shark that
senses excitement in the water right
right the the thing that freaks me out
is when they say
every x amount of feet you have to stop
and recalibrate or what the what the
[ __ ] is it equalize when you're yeah
equalize as you go deeper the the water
is pushing on any air cavities like the
ones in your ears right so you pop your
nose a little bit and you equalize that
pressure see i think i would make a
mistake and i would imagine you know i'd
implode you you'd start to feel that
that's cool
you go oh hang on a second and then you
just hold your nose and kind of just get
a little pop like you went on an
airplane did you ever make a mistake
where you start to feel that
that the pressure that
it's it's kind of like if you if you
stay ahead of it it's when you're going
down you start to
you know when you're acting
there are so many things that you know
how to do just intrinsically you never
turn your back on the camera you never
block a light on somebody else well
there's things you well i mean there's
things that you've learned in the
beginning where it's like oh my god i
have to keep track of all these
different things right but now you just
you just do them so yeah so as you go
down you know the pressure's going to
come so you kind of stay ahead of it
it's easier to stay ahead you know i
like having nathan on the podcast
because i learn a lot
have you ever missed smallville
[Music]
no really i mean it was a big part of my
life our life
okay i mean you ever feel like watching
an old episode and talking about stuff
you know
no no
never well would you would you do it for
me
no let you do it for the fans
[Music]
yeah why not
be fun
join tom welling and michael rosenbaum
every week as they rewind every episode
of smallville and discuss their
experiences with friends fans and
co-stars talkville the ultimate
smallville podcast